welcome to this video a stroke and
stroke from Norway yeah again in them so
yeah I play this very often but it's
just a good opening what can you do
let's see ok may i get the hoop now it's
one of the most interesting lines in the
NIMS own very complex middle games
before yeah this is also possible ok sky
is knowing some curio some theory here i
have very complicated the very very
complicated term line strategically
speaking
it all involves around the question when
white if right and when white plays d5
okay he's doing something different this
is another way to play it interesting f4
exactly in this position
okay yeah okay let's see yeah the this
he can take on before now this is some
this is some an interesting way to play
this book takes before I know it looks a
bit crazy but take sandy form gives a
white a very substantial center okay
here i can take on I can take on on each
who I think ok I'm going to take not
spending more time here okay so Bishop
f5 is answered with a four it's a bit
difficult I don't want to to have my
night routine so I have my night yet
totally offside I think know let's let's
go back D 5 D Fire doesn't move that I
have some definitely have some um
worries about he has a very strong
Center he is an IG for maybe to allow f5
the right moment maybe
the other move that I'm not sure about
this Queen if and I can take f6 forget
about that attending bit early for half
this was an idea be fine I don't know I
have to play me again I was sort of
falling asleep I had to play this set
play this quicker ok this was the idea
of getting the counter play here with b5
Bishop to b5 also i want the night to be
able to go to d7 if he goes he 5d
fighters hanging so it's not so easy to
just break through well it was an
interesting way to play at how in what
he did is interesting some very sharp
way to play white is very often playing
in this kind of this kind of spirit try
to really trying to use his bishop am
this way bit mystified because do you
have hangs but we can't play Bishop b5
but this is not really yeah it's not
really the kind of move you want to play
you want your pawns rolling in the
sender I'm not sure that he's managing
that now you can take b5 and play the
six of course
I immediately 93 is awesome now I sorry
beef I thinks it's anonymous hmm very
weird stuff ok let's take and try to not
spend any more time yeah this is still
may be compensation and some way forward
the pawn on d6 is something to something
to take care of
trying to do for Knight b6 now I'll
maybe just take it and but okay you can
take with the airport which looks kind
of uncomfortable
yeah not a happy move but what can you
do check
yo night it's not helping much might be
six I mean it's not really helping much
night here to just take I don't really
understand any of that that's very very
tough to play he's got rugby seven yeah
yeah I just saw it
Wow good rookie age I hope I ask God to
give got Queen f7 wow what a position
but maybe look a one as a move no is
directly going for the kill hmm time
morning bishop f6 wow now I didn't see
that move coming
well very nicely played
very nicely played check check hmm can
play d 7 at the end very nice can I
somehow Jeff stop that check night
cannot he cannot and it was a check it's
with a chick I can sorry I can't stop a
check maybe check
no and water I'm allowing them to remove
his chick none what the heck check
checkmate oh my god what did i do here I
mean he was no ah I just know I it was
completely unnecessary all of that yeah
i mean he's completely winning of class
he just has to play this and I resign
yeah it was just a final final trick and
but he he played he just took it yeah
after which i'm ok again and now i
forgot that he has 93 I just have to
play King g7 or whatever and then
probably winning ever the exchange Oh
move over yeah 93 how silly is that
dosent total disbelief that the game was
still on I mean this is just like giving
giving away all the points for nothing I
mean ok when he had a deserved winner i
played it really nicely but if he
blunders like that i really should
should win yeah yeah a very very
complicated position here jam very
difficult to say i don't really believe
in that yeah this is this kind of thing
if I've Bishop b5 it's probably not very
good but it's um it's still very very
complicated stuff never dead it's hard
to play very hard to play I mean I was
thinking that maybe I'm worse when bini
when you went for that but oh here what
did I do yeah i mean i can take probably
this is really better right
yeah I really underestimated this a bit
with t6j I played that really nicely
rupee 7 all that is very strong my
original intention was that here I
thought that here I have this kind of
thing but yes this this is strong too
strong check check check check yeah just
like that you're here yes to of course
can have to wait oops that's it and for
some reason he took it check yeah I'm
just winning and I didn't do it okay
thanks for watching